man man BJ someone we chosen Black
Panther man I'm so hyper man I'm so
hyper Black Panther I was I was sold on
Black Panther already right like I was
already sold on Black Panther chadwick
boseman amazing like Panther in Captain
America Civil War but then I saw Michael
B Jordan was in the movie and I'm just
like sold done I my butt is in the scene
because my general rule when it comes to
actors is like I will watch anything if
Michael B Jordan is it could be a movie
of Michael B Jordan watching paint peel
on a wall and I would be like that was
riveting it was amazing all right so
here's the deal
Black Panther is finally getting this
dude right and the funny thing about
Black Panther is he's like one of the
most criminally underrated heroes in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe he's
always overlooked because he's kind of
been part of the Avengers kind of not I
mean he was an Avenger but he's always
like the one guy who's overlooked right
here's a crazy thing
Wakanda in Marvel Comics is the richest
and the most technologically advanced
country in the world it's crazy how
advanced it is a lot of people don't
know that like the technology in Wakanda
puts the rest of the world to shame no
one is on the same level as Wakanda but
wakanda's wealth and wakanda's resources
all come from vibranium and the way to a
kind of timeline played out was that it
was just a territory in like Africa it's
you know somewhere along the line that
was really eight it was just a place out
there somewhere and then eventually a
giant meteorite of my vibranium like
crashed in Wakanda it was discovered by
like mashenka and a handful of other
people I think it was and then mashenka
basically formed the Black Panther clan
now the Black Panther clan derives their
whole purpose in protecting the you know
vibranium the great mound I think is
what it's called but protecting the
vibranium and then they use that as
their source of revenue let they kind of
keep it hidden and every once in a while
like they'll sell off a little piece of
it for like a ridiculous amount of money
but what Conda is the only place where
you can find what Condon vibranium
there's Antarctic vibranium
but it's not as good it's an anti metal
it just cuts through virtually anything
but what common vibranium has the
ability to amplify magical properties
and that's why it's so sought after by
like everybody and so because of that
like it makes what kind of worth a
fortune but the whole Black Panther clan
just like derives themselves from their
purpose of protecting the great mound
and they get their powers from the
Panther God now here's the crazy thing
back in the day the Panther God was like
just in Egyptian god it was a god it was
just worshipped by the Egyptians and
then somehow or another and I don't
really think it's even explained but
somehow or another people are Wakanda
and you know really in the area of
Africa outside of Egypt started going
through and worshipping bast and then
eventually the Panther clan - driver
powers from bast and they have to go to
like these rituals and eat the heart
shape herb and so on and so forth to
gain their abilities anyway there's been
all kinds of change it's like wakanda's
waxed and waned over the years really
the most significant moment in wakanda's
history came in two forms
the first was a story called dumore
which is amazing and the second one is
Avengers vs. x-men dune war was a story
where like Victor Von Doom was like okay
I have magical powers and vibranium has
the ability to amplify magical powers if
I take all the vibranium in Wakanda
it'll amplify my magical power to like
an infinite degree and I'm Doctor Doom I
do bad stuff because you know I'm Doctor
Doom like the name just screams bad guy
and so I'm gonna go do bad guy stuff and
so what happened is that in the city of
Wakanda Black Panther had taken the
stance where he was like okay it's time
for us to step out into the world it's
time for us to play more of a role and
the earthly landscape in the you know
society as a whole we have to stop being
reclusive and so because of this it was
like it's fundamental it's like crazy
group that wanted to remain totally
isolated from the rest of the world and
they basically like instigated a coup
and like they ran black panther and his
sister sharee out of the country now at
the time Black Panther had been injured
I think or something along the lines and
his sister sure he had taken over the
role of white panther form like T'Challa
had been injured and so she had become
the new black panther but they were both
basically ousted and so Doctor Doom it
turns out was the one who basically
instigated this coup by backing the
group they wanted to take over what
Conda so this leads them screaming huge
conflict right I mean like everybody
gets called in like the x-men the
Avengers the whole nine yards like that
Fantastic Four like everybody who's
anybody it's just like off to Wakanda
like we got to go there at the end of
the whole conflict kid oh my god it's so
and say at the end of the whole conflict
no one can stop Victor Von Doom right
like he's just like dr. Doom's just got
like an exorbitant amount of power -
he's got like all the Wakanda or all the
older vibranium that exists in Wakanda
his power is insane
so Black Panther is like I'm gonna do
the only thing I can do I'm going to
render all vibranium across the world
totally inert so all vibranium is
rendered useless it's just a giant hunk
of rock
what Conda loses everything I mean it
loses it all I guess absolutely must
compounded the fact that during the
story Avengers vs. x-men name when a
Submariner hit like attacked Wakanda and
basically obliterated the city like
T'Challa was ousted as like Panther and
like sure he took his place and so it
was it was one of the craziest things
ever but during Hickman's run during
Hickman's time when he was writing
Avengers and New Avengers he introduced
a whole bunch of stuff in like Lokhande
landscape and one of the things that he
introduced is that Black Panther is the
king of the dead quote-unquote now it
was really just kinda like a terminology
I mean he could like commune with all
the other former Black Panthers who had
died in battle or died of old age
whatever the case may be but he could
talk to all of his ancestors but it
became really important during the
events of secret Wars it was one of the
coolest things ever because Secret Wars
happens the multiverse collapses come
going through so much stuff right now
the multiverse collapses are a god
Kingdom where Doctor Doom is just like
I'm taking the power of the beyonders
and making myself God whatever he
creates battle world conflict ensues
anyway black panther and a handful of
others survived the collapse of the
multiverse and dr. Stephen strange grab
B and grab the Infinity Gauntlet and was
like hey if dr. doom kills me what she
did like here's the Infinity Gauntlet
use that to defeat dr. doom it didn't
work because he was just too powerful
but like a black panther got the
Infinity Gauntlet and it was a coolest
thing because like there's this amazing
image where he's just like ahhh and he's
got like the Infinity Gauntlet in his
hand it's just like brah you know it's
like the coolest thing ever and so he
ends up going to like the Marvel Zombies
universe you know and like he gathers
all the marbles Ami's like neighborhood
submariners with a man named oars like
dude there Marvel Zombies man like you
can't can you can't make them do what
they want or you can't make them do what
you want he's like don't forget man I'm
the king of the Dead and like he
controls dude it's the craziest thing
ever there's like this crazy battle
going on for battle world right like
this crazy world like everybody who's
battling Victor Von Doom
and it comes to Charla our incomes black
panther opens this portal and it's just
like an army of Marvel Zombies just come
pouring out the jealous got like the
Infinity Gauntlet he's like oh power
like it's the craziest thing ever it's
one of the coolest moments in the
history of Marvel Comics the point that
I'm making here is black panther is
badass
like he's one of the coolest guys ever
he's also like a third smartest man on
the planet but uh oh god I'm so high for
this movie you know so I'm sure this
movie man I think it's gonna be one of
the greatest things ever I think it's
gonna be one of the coolest movies that
we get to see what the character of like
Panther um because he's finally getting
this do right I mean on a more serious
note in autumn or serious no common down
coming to have us calm down everybody
listen let's relax let's calm down
let's breathe on a more serious note
Black Panther has been one of the most
integral and important parts of like
color book legacy right Oh black comic
book history Black Panther paved the way
for Luke Cage for Falcon Sam Wilson for
storm for a lot of the african-american
community within marvel comics but it
was also this idea that he has
intrinsically played a significant role
throughout Marvel Comics just in the
Marvel Comics continuity his
intelligence his technology his
resources communing with the Panther God
all those different things what this
does is it brings this wholly new legacy
into the realm of Marvel Comics not even
the sense of justice contributions to
african-american culture but take like
take like the Panther got vast right and
in Doctor Strange that was as close as
we got to like godlike beings and Doctor
Strange is probably where we're going to
start seeing like cosmic entities but
like they reference the Living Tribunal
and in Doctor Strange they were like
like Mordor was like this is the staff
of the Living Tribunal and everybody in
the theater was just like what there was
a coolest thing ever
because one of the coolest reactions
they were already sort of freaking out
but um but anyway like they referenced
the Living Tribunal to cosmic entities
in Marvel Comics you have cosmic
entities and then you have gods and gods
take a multitude of different forms you
have the sky fathers who are like the
gods that you imagine around the world
right now so like the judeo-christian
God and
like Vishnu and like Odin and Zeus those
are like the sky fathers it's like this
Council of like modern-day gods and hang
out but then you've got like a ton of
other gods and stuff like that vast is
one of them it's a whole different thing
and what this does is it brings in all
kinds of stuff like now they can start
doing things like m4 they can say ha
little do you know Freya is not the
mother of four it's actually um damn
what is her name
she's like mother earth Gaia that's what
it is Gaia is like the mother of Thor
like mother earth basically the godly
representation of like Earth Spirit
there's something wrong those lines I
don't represent go plan it oh it's one
of those weird things that goes on in my
economics but there's a lot of different
things that they can do with with the
Marvel landscape now just by virtue of
what black panther is going to introduce
but it it changes everything now because
what this is going to do is sue me to do
it right which I have full faith that
Marvel will do it right it'll make Black
Panther one of the most important
characters in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because of his resources and
his intelligence those are going to be
the things are going to make him so
significant now how smart they're going
to make him I don't know
because in Captain America's Civil War
there wasn't really a whole lot of room
to focus on his intelligence because he
was more of like you know a revenge
character right he's just like I am
going to kill the Winter Soldier because
you know I've been tricked into
believing that he's the one that killed
my dad it made sense that was the con
find of his character I wasn't focusing
on his intelligence or anything like
that but this can do that because Black
Panthers trained it like all the best
schools like some of the best schools in
the world like he's got all kinds of
degrees and so on and so forth and he's
super smart in terms of what he's
capable the point of this Black Panther
is going to be amazing I'm really
excited I think it's going to be one of
the coolest movies that comes out in
quite some time but anyway guys my
little spiel and just I'm really really
excited I'm really hyped I'm gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
I will catch you guys later peace